[Music]
hello
i'm stuart brand from the long now
foundation and sort of at the long now
foundation in the
interval or a bar in san francisco
pretty quiet right now because of the
pandemic
we're shooting in a very socially
distancely
responsible way so all the speaker
tonight and i are both
in the bar where some distance will just
come together on the screen
um the talk has been uh
recorded and edited to about a little
over half an hour
uh and so it is a very refined
presentation in that respect and then it
goes improvisational
after the talk when uh the speaker and i
uh go live with you and if you have
questions during it uh
depending on what medium you're coming
in put your questions there and
i'll try to add them to the discussion
cities is the subject tonight and uh
historians say that cities is where
civilization
happens uh since civilization is sort of
the customer for the long now foundation
we're always interested in uh how to
think about cities how to improve cities
and uh how the history of cities plays
out
the speaker's night in my view long-time
friend
long-time colleague i knew him before he
was even the state
architect with sam van der rohen and
here in california
he has been one of the major designers
of cities
uh not only with various ideas which
spread everywhere like
new urbanism and walkability but also in
terms of actually designing
real cities some cases new cities in
china
redesigning uh cities everywhere
uh he's got some ideas we'll hear about
currently uh how to make things work
better in california
and please welcome a guy who really
shapes cities which shapes
civilization peter calthorpe
well thank you stuart uh cities
over the long run climate change is
going to
hurt millions if not billions if we
cannot cope with it in a serious way
it's an existential threat the way we
live is that the
essence of how we deal with that issue
and the way we live is the product of
the environment we build
when we build a city we build a set of
behaviors
we build our own lifestyle our
relationships
to nature our relationships to each
other our relationships to money
you know they're all prescribed in ways
that we even stop
seeing we just take for granted that
this is the normal way
of being and so much is predetermined by
the way we shape our cities that i think
it's the most potent
tool we have to confront a lot of
our long challenges not our short
challenges
now a lot of projections show that
we're going to get to 70 of the global
population in cities
cities are where 80 percent of the
economic activity is
it's where 70 of the energy gets used
we're going to add another 3 billion
people to cities
largely in the emerging economies in the
global south
but we're also going to remake our
cities as well in the next
30 40 years and we've got to get it
right
but this is what cities do it's where
innovation happens it's where people go
for economic opportunity it's where
women get a chance to have standing in
their society
it's where education and literacy takes
off
it's where economic growth happens for
developing
societies and it is proven many times
over
that it's the low carbon way to live and
it's the lightest footprint on the earth
meanwhile we look at what's around us
and it's becoming more and more painful
homelessness racism the early impacts of
climate change whether it's fire or
flooding
these are things that are upon us now we
have to think systemically about them
cities are our biggest opportunity to
stop
being wasteful of land of energy
of materials of human potential
and so these are the big challenges we
have but i
i think in shaping the city we can solve
them all
in some kind of comprehensive way i
think one of the reasons we're
least capable of getting at our deepest
problems is
we live in stove pipes specialists
dealing with specialized
issues so affordable housing becomes a
stovepipe
that doesn't really recognize that for
example where a house is
is just as important as how expensive a
house is
because the farther you travel the more
it burdens your household economy
but it also burdens the environment it
also helps cause
climate change they're all nested
they're all interconnected but each
item on this little slide here is a
special interest group
it's a special professional group of
people it's
non-profit organizations that advocate
for one at a time
it is institutions within our political
structure it's all stove
piped and of course i think urban form
is what
links it all together you can't solve
one
problem without solving many problems
that's the good news of the situation
that's
what's wonderful about cities and so i
can organize these things
i see the linkages you know there are
these
cluster of challenges and then they link
to
for example travel behavior connects to
lots of different things
land use technology how much congestion
there is
how much energy there is but it all
funnels down to travel behavior and
travel behavior
is a product that that can be adjusted
through urban form
land consumption urban form just tells
us how much land we
need to consume how many resources we
need to step on
infrastructure efficient inefficient
all of it goes and interacts with the
economic domain the ecological domain
and the social domain they're all
together
so over the last 30 years we've
developed software that allowed us
to understand all the layers of
information
build scenarios and analyze the
scenarios it's now become a product any
designer or planner or city official can
have it's called urban footprint
and it has an astounding
set of capabilities millions and
millions of data
that relate to the built environment
uh a thousand plus data sets and it's
growing all the time
the ability to build hypothetical
futures
so we can actually investigate what
works and what doesn't
and in what arenas it works and then
finally
the scenario testing for the different
models it allows you to visualize
all the consequences understand the
environment in ways that
were really too invisible now let's
think globally for a minute every city
has
qualities that are universal
like the distance you and i can walk is
universal
phenomena the distance we can recognize
the face or hear
a voice those are all physical
parameters
that every city attends to in some way
and have urban design consequences
but there are different categories of
cities
now and i've broken them into three and
they are
uh framed around what i see as the
biggest challenges
one is low-income sprawl most of the
developing world
low-income population arrives you know
the favelas that are deeply embedded in
the
cities those are the rare ones most of
the development
happens at the periphery and the
low-income population is
isolated and distant from the culture
the economic
opportunities of the social uh capital
that a city has to offer
and that isolation is debilitating it
also hurts the environment
high density sprawl sounds like an
oxymoron but china has perfected this
they're building high-rise cities
in the periphery of every major city
that is
effectively sprawled because it isolates
uses it isolates people
and so density isn't really equivalent
to sprawl so urbanism
and density have nothing to do with each
other it's about
the nature of the space and how they
connect what is the connecting fabric
now i don't call what we have low
density sprawl i call it high income
sprawl
environmentally it's very very demanding
it's it's a kind of landscape that can
be only sustained by
massive wealth and quite frankly it's a
kind of development that has already
fell of its own way internal weight 2008
was the manifestation of that
but a lot of people think 2008 was all
about
subprime mortgages and wall street
ripping us off and
and bad fiscal controls the reality was
it was that we built too much of the
wrong kind of housing in the wrong place
and that the working class the workforce
of this country
could no longer afford distant
single-family dwellings it wasn't just
the mortgage that got
jiggered down it was the traveling
the commuting that it that it
represented with all of its economic and
social consequences
so this just shows chicago around the uh
2000 most of the foreclosures pretty
evenly spread
uh in 2008 all the foreclosures are in
the distant suburbs nobody talks about
that
where was this happening this was
happening in places where people had to
drive till they qualify that was the
slogan the
real estate agents have if you couldn't
afford a house here just drive another
10 miles and you'll afford a house there
when transportation gets to be 20 of the
household income
that's a big number that means that
where you choose to live is
50 60 of what you earn
and so i would say the middle class
suburb
has collapsed and we haven't found our
way back
so let's bring that home california
only 50 percent of the people in
california can afford
the rent or the mortgage on the average
house
it's because we have a deficit of the
right kind of housing
housing that's intrinsically affordable
smaller
closer in more walkable neighborhoods
that's affordable
those three things alone would solve our
housing problem
but the dilemma of course is where do
you put it
and what are the politics of that so we
used footprint to look at
statewide scenarios where do we put the
next 10 million people
in one scenario the standard business as
usual
la look like this under more compact
infill look at the difference profound
same number of people
actually in better locations now does
everybody
need and want a private yard that may be
the most profound question
are they willing to trade it for
accessibility and a great neighborhood
that they can walk through to a
neighborhood park
maybe yes but the question is where is
that walkable neighborhood with the
great park
i started drilling down very recently
into
the bay area housing crisis in the last
eight years we created almost nine
hundred thousand jobs and only a hundred
and ten thousand units of housing
it's obscene this is a map that shows
jobs housing balance
silicon valley is a giant
job machine it's red in this map
every place else has more housing but it
means that
people are commuting great distances and
that costs them too much
so let's think about building a future
with three pieces
just for simplicity sake san ramon
standard sprawl
shopping malls subdivisions office parks
rockridge a historic streetcar suburbs
one of those
low density places i still call urban
walkable mixed use
and then of course san francisco which
is not a very dense city by any
global stretch of the imagination what
if we mix those three components
and build a future for ourselves and
what if we said that the majority 65
percent was that walkable neighborhood
like rockridge
what are the consequences land
saved seven areas the size of san
francisco
saved from sprawl think of the
environmental consequences
infrastructure costs way down sooner or
later that comes
into the pocketbook of everybody miles
driven
air quality collisions and injury
insurance and of course carbon
and climate change building energy gets
more efficient
more smaller and more party walls
water use a big issue in california all
of these things get profoundly
better annual household three thousand
dollars is savings these are
serious numbers uh respiratory costs
because all the driving leads to air
quality impacts
so we can connect the dots but it
doesn't have any political
traction and so now we have to think
about well
how do you specifically engage everybody
in
the solution i started thinking about
something
a long time ago el camino i grew up in
palo alto i know it well
but the strip is the icon of the
american dream
and it's now dead and i think it's going
to nose dive even more after covet
so there's a lot of wasted land there so
i wondered
how much 43 miles historic
footprint tells us that it's not
vulnerable to flooding or fire
these are the overlay maps so you can
see that but that's what it looks like
the cool thing is it's in every
community if you're going to
put housing into the inner areas of
silicon valley
or the inner bay area where it's easy to
move around using bart
and things are close you want to
distribute it you don't want to say one
city you're going to solve the problem
everybody else
has what if it became positive space
what if it became the space
in which we solved the housing crisis
what if it looked like this
totally feasible because that land is
underutilized and under taxed so
this is footprint looking for parcels of
land
that front on el camino and or are near
caltrain stations they're in red here
they end up being
enough for a quarter of a million
households
at a range of densities from townhouse
all the way and simultaneously those
houses
all have these other environmental and
economic benefits
so then what about the rest of the bay
area
so we did the same kind of screening
discovered
fifteen thousand acres of underutilized
commercial land
in these ribbons all around the bay
interestingly enough 1.2 million units
a lot of it in santa clara where you
would want it to be
so we have a housing solution we need to
make
the solution ubiquitous we need to have
it support a whole new network
of mobility and what we've got with
barton caltrains and a few other things
just not enough furthermore we can't put
a heavy foot
on existing neighborhoods you can't draw
a circle around
a transit station and say we're going to
wipe out these neighborhoods
they're historic they're beloved in some
cases sometimes they're affordable
housing
you don't want to be heavy-handed you
want to be precise
the beauty of the tools we have is that
we can be incredibly precise
so we can go from this environment to
this environment
but the first question i'm asked about
this strategy is okay
that's a great land reservoir but if you
put you know 1.2 million people on our
quarters
isn't that going to lead to massive
congestion
and the answer is not if we rebuild
the corridor itself not if we rebuild
the street the right solution
is to give priority to
transit if transit doesn't run on a
private
congestion-free lane nobody's going to
bother with it and so brt is well-known
the most
effective so basically the bus becomes a
train on its own dedicated space
but it was affordable to a low lower
income
city and it proved to be every bit as
as good as rail transit
we don't have much of it in the bay area
we're starting to build it but el camino
is a great place for it
so this is just a very kind
picture of el camino it's 120
feet in 120 feet i can build
15 foot sidewalks tree lined i can build
bikeways i can build dedicated lanes for
transit
and i can still have six goddamn lanes
for cars
what if that brt turned into really
nimble
semi-expressed little vans where you put
in your
phone you get on a van that's pretty
much clustering origins and destinations
and
then it largely takes you directly to
your destination so rather than being on
a big bus
stopping at every station you get to be
in a small van
with a few people going direct to
destination but on a dedicated
right-of-way
so you're not fighting your way through
traffic that's a big
revolution because we've been stuck
transit-wise
in 19th century technology and i think
we can use autonomy
and that kind of intelligence to
actually enhance and build
give birth to a whole new generation of
transit the consequence of
rebuilding the strip isn't just in
building a better place and
adding housing and and building transit
and bikeways and all the rest of that
it's taking underutilized land and
creating
high enough property values that can
begin to drive our
state economy in a healthier direction a
lot of people will say well
you're going to build all this housing
but where's the parks and the schools
and all the
peripheral costs well we used to have
something called
tax increment financing which means that
the
amount of tax that comes out of a
changed land use
can be recycled into the community
put back into the local schools local
parks
build transit bikeways
there's a there would be an explosion of
economic well-being for the state and
for the cities
if we were able to capture the increased
property values that result from
re-envisioning the strip the el camino
as a grand boulevard means that
it's not just a transit corridor or it's
not just a
place with multi-family housing it's a
beautiful place you want to be
when housemen uh intervened in paris and
built
those boulevards they became a source of
pride they became a place that people
wanted to go to
so it's not just a matter of satisfying
the housing or
building new transit it's also enhancing
the community around it
okay that's america i think america can
solve
the next two uh decades of of growth by
just
reusing the gray fields that are strip
commercial has produced
china china is a place where 800 million
people
have come out of poverty by moving to
cities
it's all about speed and efficiency or
it has been
and there's not a lot of unique place
making going on they shifted to cars
and of course the pedestrian and the
bikes have gone
by the wayside this is the kinds of
place that create community
and connectedness on a local level and
human scale
and they're all going by the wayside
this is inside a super block with 5 000
units of housing
there's not a sidewalk in sight there's
not a ground floor shop
in sight this is urban
coercion the urban environment tells you
what to do
and it sure ain't walking to the
neighborhood store this is one i found
actually in one of those super blocks in
china where they had converted all the
garages to
local shops you can't stop people from
doing the right thing even if
it involves breaking the law this looks
like some weird
chess game or something but actually
it's a model of a community that we got
a chance to redesign
and these are major arterials that sit
at about 500 meters
that's over a quarter mile see only
through streets
so they're ginormous and then each block
is single use
this is exactly the same quantity of
development
and exactly the same amount of asphalt
except the red
streets are auto free so you can build
with the same investment with the same
quantitative outcome
a much more humane urban landscape so
here's chongqing this is a
city in the west 30 million population
i mean it's almost as big as california
in terms of population
very fractured landscape and they asked
us to test our ideas of walkability
sustainable environments in a study area
that
was basically equivalent to a place for
four million people
it's just north of the historic city
center and just
you can see west of the airport to the
right there in the picture
and so we applied our principles number
one being start with the natural
environment
what's the topography where are the
ecologies where the repairing cord is
preserve the things that matter to the
environment
and so the mask shows the things that
are going to be developed
and the unmasked are the preserved open
space that's the existing development
got to work with what's there and a road
network
which is essential regardless we still
have trucks buses
cars we have to move them but that
defines these zones
these areas where you can create
walkable
unimpeded unbarriered environments that
can easily connect for somebody on a
bicycle or on foot
or can be where the transit goes because
of the standards
that are now in places in china that is
a
red network of metro lines just imagine
if we spent that kind of money on
transit
i think people would actually be pretty
comfortable using it
there's a red zone in there which is a
study area that they gave us this show
but what does it look like to live in
that's the plan we did for that
particular area
human scale blocks diversity and use
walkable streets
we went from the picture on the left to
the picture on the right
we went from two large single-use zones
to a mixed-use environment built around
human scale
the green space not only preserved the
most
sensitive environmental areas at the
water's edge and made them common space
but you'll see green lines moving up
those are auto free streets
in china today depending on which city
you're at
only 20 to 30 percent of households own
cars
so i wonder why all the streets are for
cars
when 70 of the people don't own a car
so this is a boulevard that has transit
bikes and pedestrians
no cars no trucks it's a right-of-way
deserves to be
and in many many cities can be and now
in china it is
our design standard said we need one of
these every
kilometer on center so the idea of this
green setback
and diverse housing uh and mixed use
came into being is now
under construction so the third type of
city i called low-income sprawl where
the poor really are relegated to the
periphery
and the first place we worked was mexico
city and this is what
the outer skirts of mexico city look
like social housing
it's way out there why because it's
cheap land and they think they get more
bang for the buck
below much more interesting informal
housing which is self-built
and kind of rough cowboy stuff where the
property owners
just throw the land on the market and
don't worry about streets or
power or anything like that people go in
and build amazing communities
but in the wrong place way too far away
uh and of course the they have this
amazing
transit system which are kind of a
democratic form of bus where people own
their own bus and they
drive certain routes but it just means
it leads to chaos
they stop anywhere they start you know
they pull over to pick somebody up
everywhere and of course the congestion
levels are just
out of control because of that this once
again is a city
without a high auto ownership ratio
and so the the efficacy of the buses is
terribly important
so let's look at the big systemic
picture here
the wealthy are in the city center where
the culture
and the economy and the history the
human scale
and the mix is richest and the poor are
at the periphery
the jobs are all concentrated at the
center and so the poor
are even more disenfranchised by being
farther and farther away from economic
opportunity
we then mapped mobility and we said
there was one category the best where
you could walk and get
transit the second category was you
could get transit but it wasn't
really walkable the third was walkable
but no decent transit
and the fourth was none of the above
well none of the above
turned out to be 67 of the environment
there's a mobility crisis in this city
as well as an economic stratification
and we do our urban footprint scenario
planning
and we look at all these metrics design
categories are how do you
use land where do you put housing and
jobs
what kind of transport do you invest in
and what kind of urban configuration
is it walkable human scale or is it
single and
and auto oriented and then even more
bewildering is this matrix of
outcomes but for those people who really
care about the future of that city
being able to see that there's a linkage
between
uh the land consumption water being a
big issue
air quality infrastructure costs
travel time for low-income populations
all of these things can be arrayed so
that
coalitions begin to come together
because each one of these columns
represents a different special interest
group
and if they can actually say hey what
works for me works for you
you then have coalition building that
you didn't know about
and so the chemistry of the politics can
change
now i'm right in the midst of working on
ho chi minh city
and it's an amazing city of 9 million
people
it's grown at a massive rate i mean this
is the classic picture
of a successful developing nation
central city and of course it's in
the delta vietnam is one of the most
floodplain
countries in the world it's nothing but
one long coastline
most of its population is on the coast
where it's vulnerable
to climate change sea rise and typhoons
you can see throughout existing ho chi
minh city
a lot of development in the flood plain
literally right
out over the water this is our mapping
of ho chi minh city the orange is
existing development in the flood zone
about
400 square kilometers and then they have
a master plan that shows
more development in the floodplain
another 500 square kilometers
mckinsey recently did a study for a 2050
kind of high-end climate change sea rise
scenario
and massive quantities of development
infrastructure key infrastructure
was put out of use and so they can't
afford the future that they're building
the first thing we want to do is map
resettlement areas areas that were
high ground the yellow areas are
approximately high ground
some of it is close to the existing city
some of it is distant
so and i ironically i've been uh
bad mouthing new towns for a long long
time and yet
this is a case study for moving to high
ground
for the next generation of people and
building a new city
up there in the area b c and d
sparsely populated high ground
connected to uh ho chi minh city
and you have to connect the region
they're building metro
it's very expensive and very difficult
for them the
ecological systems around this kind of
wet humid environment necessitates
a lot of green space a lot of
water flow and detention areas and of
course they're filling it all up with
with development the waterways that
exist
are impounded by solid waste
so they need a much healthier recycling
system
so the stuff doesn't end up in the
waterways and and cause more flooding
now this is the part that i'm most
excited about
in this case i look at at vietnam
everybody's on a motorcycle 90
percent of trips are on motorcycles it's
more unique
more variable more uh consumer friendly
but the problem of course is you jam it
into streets that are filled with cars
and buses and trucks
and all of a sudden nobody's moving so
why not give
motorcycles what we give transit a
private right-of-way
so traffic engineers and transit
engineers think of
capacity in terms of peak hour how many
people can pass through
a point which gives you the quantity of
flow
and so you start at one end very low 2
000 cars
can get through a lane in an hour then
you go all the way up to
mass transit and you can have 80 000
people if you take a bicycle
which is 14 000 passengers per lane
but then you factor it up for the higher
speeds of the motorcycle and maybe for
one and a half people
all of a sudden you're into 30 000
passengers
per lane which is higher than light rail
so you could give just space to the
motorcycles and you'd be doing
as well if not better than light rail
for almost no cost so why not give
streets just to motorcycles
so this is our prototypical street
network and the orange streets
are motorcycle streets the purple
streets are mixed flow streets
and then there are local streets that
just go to your doorstep
don't go anywhere else so there's no
through traffic
and so this is what we're experimenting
with is actually form-fitting
the solution to the culture it's
technically feasible
those orange streets filled with
bikes and bicycles could be all electric
and all of a sudden you have
probably the best transportation system
on the planet
so that's really one of my favorite
things the other thing of course is
housing there's so many different types
of housing but i'll tell you
one that i just fell in love with which
is actually the normative housing type
they call them shop houses there's
always a ground floor shop
there's always something happening the
second category is informal where people
build their own
you have to make space for that because
that's actually
one of the healthiest way to produce
housing and you know they get a little
plot of land and they build
something small and then as the family
grows they keep adding
height to it and so what we do has to
have space for that
they need social housing and they're
building it affordable housing
and new development interestingly enough
already does
it looks pretty sterile but it's good in
certain ways because there are shop
houses
there are high-rise condos they're
affordable housing and they're all
together
carbon emissions you can see on the
bottom set of graphs
from 1995 to 1915 the
increase in ambient temperature in the
urban center
and it's because they don't have streets
big enough to breathe they don't have
street trees
they don't have open spaces that allow
the breeze to move through
they need to put incorporate all of that
sensibility into their next
great city the walkable neighborhood
idea
and it has these elements all the daily
destinations
within the neighborhood schools shops
parks everywhere you would go on a daily
basis is right there
a whole range of housing types the
wealthy get their high-rise condos
the affordable apartment buildings the
shop houses
line the motorcycle streets uh and then
the self-built sites and services where
you give them a road you give them a
piece of land you give them
utility hookups and then they take it
from there the point being that
these are all integrated in one place
they're not separated
across the landscape in the city these
are really big principles and you'll
note
the quantity of open space which is
proportional to the need
for the ecological environment of a kind
of
permeable environment in which you can
absorb the rainwater and detain it in a
way that doesn't
lead to flooding here's a one of our
sites that we're studying for growth
there
800 000 population it's more than san
francisco
it sits on 15 square miles and yet
each one of those red dots is the center
of a neighborhood
with lots of open space and local
services and there's a big armature of
open
base that works ecologically and from
recreation standpoint
so there are big solutions i'll conclude
with
uh another project i'm working on right
now for the world bank which was
everybody says there is no such thing as
a universal solution
and i actually think that's
fundamentally wrong and because we don't
conceive of universal solutions we
wander
around as if we don't know what to do
but there's all sorts of things
that are fundamentally correct no matter
where you are and i'm going to give you
a list
first is you need to understand and
preserve natural ecology's
history and culture many places actually
in their rush to development overlook
all of that
the urban growth foundry is the one
dimension
of this particular principle that you
need to preserve
what's most valuable in a place that's a
universal principle
and you can actually assign specific
actions to making it
real you can map where all the
ecological
and endangered species are you can
isolate
buildings and historic places second is
mixed use
there's no great city that isn't mixed
use this is a universal
principle what does mixed use mean
it means that instead of zoning by use
here's one kind of housing here there's
a shopping center here
there's an office park here and they
don't overlap
they don't combine they're isolated and
separate
mix use literally puts things side by
side
say within a city block or even
vertically
so housing over shops but mixed use also
has a more profound
meaning that you don't build one kind of
housing for one income group
in one place you mix different housing
opportunities together
so there's a range of people all
interacting
in their common area you know mixed use
also means
bring nature into the environment rather
than putting it
in a separate category somewhere else
that's what people desire that's what
people love and it's actually the most
robust socially because it involves the
kinds of
interaction that makes society civil
connections the scale of development
there are absolutes there the human body
describes a human scale and connections
really have to
be framed there that's another universal
principle
public space architects focus on
buildings objects you've got to think
about the space between the buildings
that's where
life happens and that's where the life
of a culture in a city happen
and you can actually talk about what
scale
the neighborhood parks are how frequent
they should be
and what kind of regional and cultural
facilities need to happen at what scale
these are all knowable principles
no great place is without walking and
biking
and there are some very simple rules
about that
you know how wide should a bike lane be
we know it's the same here
as it is anywhere else in the world we
can actually put it down and say this is
a universal
best practice we need to enhance transit
certainly we've had an explosion of all
sorts of local mobility forms and that's
all very exciting
you need to make space in our
right-of-ways for all of that
and we need to focus we need to use
those modes
as the armature of growth we need to
stop using freeways
as the framework of our city and we have
to start
making walkable streets and transit
networks
the the armature around which we grow
the city so these are all things we know
and we can actually quantify and we can
quantify
the benefits and it doesn't hurt to have
a checklist
and it's exciting the world bank would
say yes we're interested
in having something like that because
when we give you
massive amounts of money for
infrastructure maybe we'd like to see a
checklist here
of best practice in building cities so i
have lots of hope about the future
of cities clearly and i have hope that
it solves our most
uh intransient uh problems
thank you thank you peter that was
fantastic i love ending with the sort of
the menu of things to do right and then
we can proceed
um so you and i are semi together
in this bar in san francisco
unfortunately it's empty and we get to
not wear masks
because we're far enough apart um
but it raises the the question of of
covet of a pandemic
basically everything you're saying is uh
the denser
uh we live the more congested we are
basically
sitting on top of each other in cities
the better but isn't that a bit of a
problem in a time of
pandemic you know there's no evidence at
all
that that's the case uh some of the
places on the planet that have been
most successful in beating back the
covet are highly urban places
japan has succeeded south korea has
succeeded singapore is a model
of of low transmission rates
and you know it's ironic you even look
in the united states manhattan of the
five
boroughs has the lowest incident rate
now
of any other place so there's no
correlation between
urbanism and covet spread covet spread
is about
behavior it's about how people act
you know if you go to a restaurant that
isn't well ventilated and there's not
the proper spacing uh it doesn't matter
if it's
in a 30-story building or sitting in a
parking lot at a shopping mall
you have the same problem so it's
it's more about human behavior and our
lack of
ability to bring ourselves to some kind
of
simple level of control well speaking of
city and parking lots
i was sitting in the middle of a street
in
sausalito the other night having dinner
and
um five or six restaurants they're
lined up on caledonia street uh with
nobody inside everybody out in the
street everybody looking pretty happy
and pretty much everybody's saying how
come we can't do this
all the time and the uh the the lowering
of
the cities that that are dealing with
the pandemic the
you know shut in and so on uh there's
less street traffic and
in terms of cars but more hanging out
in terms of people um do you think we're
going to go back or is this now a new
era for cities that people want to do
more of
the way you want them to do or just hang
out
in public you know that was happening
before covet
i mean new york city had been taking
back lanes uh we'd been
uh pushing parking stalls aside for
sidewalk cafes and and bars
and the whole sense that more asphalt
will solve our mobility problems
is pretty much a dead dead on arrival
concept at this point
people are excited by alternative ways
of getting around
whether they're electric scooters and
tricycles and
um and more and more biking and more and
more walking
this is what people are voting for
as they move now they want to be in in
places that are
better connected and have more uh have
richer public spaces
um it's not a mystery you know when you
go on vacation
you don't go to a shopping mall
you tend to go to a historic city where
you can walk and enjoy
the places and the sense of place that's
been created over
an incredible amount of time in history
um
so i think that there's predating this
recent phenomena uh a pretty large
movement
there was a stunning uh article in new
york times
uh published illustrating uh
a proposition what if we got rid of
private automobiles on manhattan island
and the images that you see are
extraordinary and all of a sudden you
realize well wait a minute
actually you don't need um to have all
those private automobiles people can get
around on taxis and buses and
bikes and walk and it all
clearly will work there's no mystery
the problem is well how can you do that
in the american suburb
which was designed around the car you
know everything is framed for the car
everything has a giant asphalt
apron around it for parking your car
but i see that i call them the gray
fields as the great opportunity
we can infill our way redesign those
places and redevelop them
that's what the el camino grand
boulevard idea is all about is we should
take the worst places
in our communities and transform them
does it mean
that people will lose use their cars
less yeah
and some people will be very stressed by
that they want
to be free to move at 60 miles an hour
whenever they want to
but the reality of course is that they
don't get to do that the average
mobility speed in most urban areas is
pretty low now
and so getting on a brt
system or getting on what i call art
autonomous rapid transit
is wait a minute wait a minute okay so
bus rapid transit autonomous rapid
transit but
supposedly self-driving cars or
autonomous vehicles are going to come
along and save the city all by
themselves isn't that
the case that's the hype but the reality
is by
any analysis it'll just generate
massive multiples of vehicle miles
traveled in other words
the average amount of car
on the road driving miles will increase
why
well let's say you have your own
autonomous vehicle
you take it to work maybe you send it to
a distant parking lot because it's
cheaper than
parking near where you work that's extra
miles maybe you send it home
so somebody else uses it all day so now
you've
done a four-way commute so the numbers
there are about a 30 percent increase in
average
vehicle miles traveled per household
so let's take the second case the uber
and
and um uh the uh taxi services
become autonomous there's something
called deadhead
which is when a car is circular circling
looking for the next passenger
or actually going to the to the call
location
and that represents easily a 50 to 60
percent
increase in vehicle miles traveled uh
and so
if you uh have a single passenger
environment with those autonomous
vehicles you give up your car
you think your hip um you're still
generating more traffic
and using more energy now it's all
equal if it's everything gets
electrified but the congestion level
and the environment still suffers by
this
multiplication of travel so congestion
will go through the ceiling if we get
autonomous vehicles if we can get them
to work now that's a whole nother matter
now if we use them on dedicated lanes
as transit vehicles all of a sudden they
become
completely benign they're not traveling
empty
they're not traveling uh extra miles
they're on a route
and they're serving more and more people
so uh it's classic case it's
it's technology if you use it well it's
great if you use it poorly
it can be incredibly destructive well
how would that work if
you have bus rapid transit it has its
own lane buses come and go
can they blend with autonomous vehicles
that are maybe smaller
that can do more kind of dedicated
trips sort of like those informal buses
that you saw in the informal cities that
you like
yeah it's complex there'll be a complex
uh
transition i think we'll start building
dedicated lanes
and don't forget we shouldn't measure
the world by america i mean this is the
mentality we all have like this is the
way we are
and therefore uh it's really the only
way to live
in most of the world people are transit
bike
pedestrian bound most of the world
people don't own
cars and so
they how effective those private routes
are
or auto free streets that i like to
throw into my projects whenever i can
those create environments where you can
mix the autonomous the small autonomous
with the larger
bus and once again once the
communication system between the
vehicles gets sophisticated enough the
passing lanes can all be used as
uh into oncoming traffic believe it or
not and so you you get more and more
efficiency
that's one of the promises of autonomous
technology is that it can be very
efficient in how vehicles communicate
with one another
you're going to bring back the
three-lane highway i can just see it
that's really remember the passing lane
in the middle where you took your life
in your hands when you were out there
yeah that's right no actually i've got
that on the drawing board stewart
said in several cases okay here's a
question from online from
gill friend at facebook it begins this
is a great vision peter and well
grounded
i agree he says completely sensible
but sensible isn't what drives politics
what's been your experience in
overcoming resistance to change both in
general
and from folks who fear negative impacts
and i mean here's an example you know we
got the housing issue
in the bay area and there's the nimbys
saying never in my
backyard and the envy's saying no by god
yes in my backyard and they're duking it
out that's politics
yeah and politics shifts with different
kinds of coalitions and different kinds
of
economic and environmental forces and so
things are changing
you know it was uh 1988 i went to
portland
and worked for an environmental group
there that wanted to
preserve the urban growth boundary by
not allowing a new beltway freeway to be
built
outside of that line and and there
catalyze more sprawl and we proposed the
the west side light rail line and the
whole idea of transit oriented
development
was first planted was
not only would we take the money from
that freeway and use it for a transit
line
but we would then zone for density at
each one of the stations
and lo and behold politically they've
done it
you know and it's now normative the idea
of transit owned development is
normative all over the world i mean if
you go up to canada and you look at how
toronto and and vancouver grow
it's taken for granted that transit is
the armature
and walkable neighborhoods is the
everyday development
standard so these things do change
how rapidly i don't know in america
i'm not going to sit here and argue with
you that we are
not in gridlock we're in ideological
gridlock we're in an
us and them world um and so
even rational solutions get set aside by
this kind of
mentality that we've that we've arrived
at and it's
heartbreaking to tell you the truth um
the politics let's talk about the
politics of the grand boulevard idea
uh sometimes we're going to talk to
gavin newsom our governor pretty soon i
hope about this right
yeah well we'll see i'd like to but i
want to
actually gather enough grassroots
uh support and recognition before
you go to that level but the history is
interesting there was a legislator here
from
san francisco that proposed the tod idea
and said as of right anything within a
quarter or half mile of
transit should be dense and it didn't
it wasn't careful about going into
single-family historic neighborhoods
or the avenues here in san francisco or
you know all the complexity of place
and it just said as of right we should
do this and the backlash was huge
out of that came the uh the not the
nimby zimbies who said
god damn it we're gonna stop defending
the right of
these single-family neighborhoods to you
know maintain their economic
and land-based separation
my attitude is if you can find enough
land somewhere else why step on
anybody's toes
so the strip and that all that
commercial land
that by the way amazon is making
um pure history for out of the bricks
and mortar there
why not just use what's available and
not
uh go into a protracted battle that's
unnecessary we have plenty of land we
can
it's in the right place in the sense
that it's near where we can put
transit and it's ubiquitous
um and so i think that there's something
about
in politics about just finding the
the path of least resistance and if you
can define that
um you can maybe succeed the other thing
of course is that economics and politics
go hand in hand
let's you know we all know this and one
of the reasons that cities don't want
housing is that
um it's expensive all the services
police fire
schools parks and so every city wants
jobs and no cities want housing because
of what's called fiscal zoning
so they get more taxes from job yeah
opportunities and less
taxes from housing opportunities yeah
so it turns out that on the strip
because the land has such
such low property values i mentioned
that in the clip
tax increment financing would actually
bring a lot of money to those
communities so instead of
feeling like it's our duty to build
housing even though it's going to
put us have a negative fiscal impact
they can clearly say to their community
yes we're going to add housing but we're
going to have money for parks
and transit and schools and community
facilities and bikeways and all the
things that will enrich our community
so you gotta step lightly
and you gotta think about the economics
well that relates to a question that
kevin kelly put up on
youtube if someone wanted to visit a
well-crafted
livable city in your terms uh where
would you point them
boy there's a hundred places historic
city centers
around the world you know i wouldn't say
it's a place
it's more time you know it's the time
before the automobile
became the paradigm of project uh
progress and uh the form giver
of our communities you've got some
exciting urban experiences that you sort
of hearken to when you think about what
well you want me to name names but uh
what i was about to say is that there's
an interesting
thing in the old national geographic
maps
of our country
they started coloring the urban
environment
purple at around 1962
and all the other urban fabric was pink
so if you look at those maps in just
about any pink spot is good urbanism
because we were a country of great
cities and beautiful streetcar suburbs
and and small towns that were mixed use
and walkable so there was great urbanism
everywhere
and our street cars of course were uh
bought up and destroyed by uh standard
oil and
and goodyear and one other bit of the
conglomerate i can't remember
and literally you know replaced by
buses that then tried to had had to slug
their way through
uh traffic with cars so we've got great
urbanism everywhere what's my favorite
place on the planet
geez i i just can't i mean there are too
many of them
stuart really well i'll ask you a more
embarrassing question which i ask all
architects which is uh
as you and i have talked about back and
i was working on how buildings learn
um architects don't learn because they
are careful not to go back to the
buildings they built because they were
always so
um depressed by what had happened
and different things are happening that
i planned for and uh
their maintenance issues that they were
being held accountable for
and basically uh the further the
original architect could get from the
original building the happier they were
the more unhappy the the occupants were
so uh you've designed a number of urban
places now or the ones you'd like to go
back to
you know it's ironic but it's old
sacramento
one of them you know when jerry was
governor the first time and we were all
hanging out there
we were really beginning to think
through what an
environmentally stable future would look
like
and we did a lot of fascinating things
jerry said
we're going to start building state
office buildings that are going to
define
energy efficiency and sim and i got to
design
the bateson building which is 1977
or eight yeah or five we started in 75.
and the bateson building was a low-rise
building with a courtyard
and a lot of thermal mass so climate
there is cool evenings and really hot
days so we would flush it out
and just like an old adobe building
would store the cool
as we called it we used natural lighting
and
operable windows it hadn't been done for
30 years in an office building right it
was all
smoked mirror glass and sealed
and run through an hva uh radical
and the building's still there and it's
really beautiful and then just across
the park
from that building we got to design
a housing complex that was radical
on just about every level it was
one-third market rate
one-third affordable and one-third
subsidized housing so it was an
economic mix within one city block and
we built different types of of housing
some town houses
some apartments and some ground floor
shops
uh and then most radical in terms of the
solar
solar not passive solar design always
needs thermal mass
right you need to absorb the sunlight
and
store it for when you need it or you
need it for cool night air
so we went back to using lathe and
plaster
on the walls instead of sheetrock and
the latin passer has like seven times
more thermal mass than shirak
yeah and so we found some old-timers who
knew how
to kind of re-discover that technology
but it was
interesting to me that all these things
were connected
that if you tried to solve for passive
solar design you ended up
rethinking the materials in your
building
and and how the building went together
and
how it was oriented so it was all just a
tremendous amount of fun
the most radical thing and nobody ever
gets this right but the baits in
building
famous you know it consumes just 20
percent
of the average office building and they
became the
the kind of the the benchmark
for title 24 which is california's very
famous
energy standards and buildings way
before lead and all the rest of that
we set on a course and actually because
of we have
pretty low carbon rate per capita in
this state
um and it has all this you know operable
shades and trellises and a big atrium
with
moving devices that let sunlight in in
the winter and
keep it out in the summer and you know
all this fabulous stuff
and i asked people what do you think is
the most
energy efficient part of this building
and they named this or that
the most energy efficient part was that
there was zero parking
normally a quarter million square foot
building would have
uh uh basically three times its
footprint
in asphalt surrounding it for all the
people
to show up in their cars and for
downtown sacramento
we said nope no parking people have to
figure out how to get there
on their own we added the light rail
system in sacramento at that time
so it was like a little laboratory where
we got to play around with all these
ideas and the truth is i haven't had a
good idea since i mean it's just all the
same ideas recycled
but i can't even i can't even remember
your question
stuart well there you went a good
distance there uh it does raise a
uh question that uh kim sykes asked on
youtube which is are there do you have
some thoughts or examples of making
better use of
rooftops uh especially in maybe a public
way
rooftops so rooftops at least got
realized and they also were kind of the
detritus of a building
the place where you put all of the uh
great big noisy
uh hvac heating ventilating air
conditioning apparatus
and they were basically hidden they were
flat they leaked
and roofs for semi
to be not even thought about um
but in new york at least she started
getting these little scenes up on
people's roofs that are like their own
little mini parks or something and that
was pretty cool in gardens and whatnot
and then solar came along and solar
started to occupy a number of roofs
so what's the best use of of the tops of
buildings
all of the above i mean in so many latin
countries the rooftop
is the coolest place to hang out the
breezes and the views
and the trellises and and connected
buildings their rooftops are connected
people can wander from one to another
yeah
i mean it's just a whole nother level
but once again it's not a single family
world it's a
you know it's joint it's it's an urban
environment
um and we're seeing that now in the kind
of higher density housing that does get
built around the bay area
a lot of rooftop amenities going in oh
yeah
developers are just head over heels
they've discovered something
totally new but of course it's been
around for a very long time
uh why not use the solar collectors as
shades in a trellis you know it's not
one or the other
that uh you have to play around with but
it's a it's a resource
it's one important resource just like
uh the quality of the sidewalk is a
resource
there are many things to always mix
so the in you're doing some work in los
angeles and
los angeles is famous for having
approximately no parks
um and not much public area of any kind
uh how do you fix uh an already
seriously broken situation like that
precisely say more
well i i don't think there's a you know
i love to come up with
grand principles that are universal and
but the application of a principle
always has to be very unique to the
place and very precise
you need to think about a place just
south of
south of the los angeles river that's
two blocks away from it and uh blah blah
blah
yeah yeah so you have to go in
surgically and find the right
places where you can do it once again we
did a similar analysis the el camino
analysis for la county and discovered
yes there's tremendous amount of
opportunity there and if the tax base
rises because of the infill all of a
sudden you got the money to buy land and
build parks
and more often not pocket parks small
parks
are perhaps the most valuable they're
the most
accessible local and they bring people
together in a neighborhood
more effectively than big you know
golden gate park or you know
nobody's going to say anything bad about
central park but
you know it has to happen at different
scales
i think we're heading toward wrapping up
and the
standard wrap-up question is um
you've been covering many decades of
your work and thought here where are you
at now what's
next in your mind what's next you want
to do with your
professional practice well
i'm still working on new books i've
written a lot of them and
hopefully they're helpful um
for a while i was just swept away by
working in china
because what they were doing was so
grand
and huge and so off target
that it was just a very rich domain to
to participate you know and as i said in
the clip there they
they brought more people out of poverty
than has ever been witnessed in the
history of mankind
and but to have bring them into cities
that i can see
30 or 40 years from now will be failing
just like our public housing
towers fail you know because of the
scaleless
placeless quality of it um so i was very
excited about
working there and and doing everything
that i could do so they were
both listening to you and then acting on
what you said that's
that's a rare combination uh but what
did that mean so you're working with
what
are they city managers or uh
popular people i mean what kind of no it
was a very hard
level we we we presented some ideas
to the the equivalent of derek kuvlin of
hud
and also the state council which is put
pull it barrier
urban design yeah and we said look
here's your problem look at the problem
and they all recognize they all see see
you know this qua
this this deadly quality they kept
building you know
i think they're on the ninth ring road
in beijing i mean
they keep building it thinking the next
one will fix it and it never
ever will um and they build
super blocks that are so big that the
streets that surround
them are inhospitable to anything but
cars and therefore everybody wants a car
now
everybody feels like there's no place
for them to go if they don't have a car
and then of course they're in massive
gridlock because the density is so great
so it's it was just a cascading problem
so we
presented some big ideas and they said
very science-based very secular right
let's
test these ideas so they gave us yeah
they gave us eight cities to work with
cities eight cities to go you know
different parts of the country to
experiment just to demonstrate that
small city blocks and human scale
streets and auto free streets
and mixed use and all that that litany
of
principles could actually happen in
china given
chinese culture and chinese economy and
whatnot
and after about six years of working the
answer came back and it was
yes and the state council
went into a session dedicated to urban
standards and they adopted it all
bingo i mean that's a lot easier
that's how china is building cities now
is by those principles are you telling
them
yes very much so oh it's just amazing
we'll see and then of course it will
deteriorate and be less than perfect
but that's what cities are i mean
they're always less than perfect
and it's actually all the idiosyncratic
failures that
make them really interesting
but there'll be this other force that at
least begins to write
the most egregious problems so that was
you asked me what am i
into doing now i'm into coming home this
this idea of solving the housing crisis
um you know we didn't talk a lot about
affordable housing and homelessness
but uh it's my theory that you once
again you can go out at stovepipe and
say we need affordable housing we need
non-profit groups to
get a bunch of subsidies and go out and
build affordable housing
there's in addition to that you also
need
enough housing that the economic
pressure is not pushing people down and
out
you know when you have a housing
shortage the prices go up i mean this
is economics and as the prices go up
the people at the bottom of the economic
ladder go out
they either go farther and farther into
the sacramento valley and commute all
half of their life or they go out on the
street
so i'm pretty passionate about housing
supply
getting enough housing and enough of the
right kind of housing not
everybody now can should or wants to
have a single-family dwelling it always
used to be the norm it's just
america right everybody's got to have a
house on a cul-de-sac and a couple cars
the word everybody is no longer so
simple
we're much more diverse culture uh with
all sorts of different desires and
complexities
so we should have a much more diverse
housing stock
not one size fits all anymore so i
yeah for me right at this phase i i'm
i'm interested in coming back and doing
battle
at home well thank you for doing that
thank you for speaking tonight thank you
audience for joining us
and for good questions and we'll hope to
see you at
another long now seminar about long-term
thinking
uh with another speaker as good as
peter califor good night good day good
morning
wherever you are
[Music]